this morning on the dish in an
unassuming new york city eatery with a
mighty profile brooklyn's meadow suite
is in the literal shadow of the
williamsburg bridge and for nearly its
entire existence it's had the attention
of the food world michael george made a
visit and he's here to share a taste
with us good morning michael michelle
good morning meadowsweet is the creation
of michelin star chef polo dobkin and
his wife stephanie lemper for the last
eight years they've been giving diners a
taste of the countryside in the big city
chef polo dobkin trained with some of
new york's top chefs but now at his
brooklyn restaurant meadow suite he's
found his own voice
and he expresses that voice by letting
his ingredients do the talking
seasonality simplicity and really
letting flavors kind of speak for
themselves
trying not to have anything be
overwrought or overworked sourcing some
of his best ingredients from his dad's
own garden in the hudson valley he has a
very green thumb when we first opened we
just started basically working together
planting and bringing down going up
every weekend and bringing down produce
and we basically create our menus on a
weekly basis
his creations modern american cuisine
with mediterranean inspiration like
these crispy baby artichokes topped with
shaved lemon parmesan and a creamy
garlic dressing oh this is great it
tastes very fresh
the born and raised new yorker was
already helping in the kitchen at the
age of five who did the cooking growing
up
my father did most of the cooking and
then when i got to a certain age i just
kind of started helping out did you have
the bug from the beginning or did it
take time to grow
well you know what looking back on it i
think i had the bug from the beginning
and that bug led him to volunteer at a
culinary school while paying the bills
as a bike messenger i just started
volunteering you know one day a week
then one day a week left to two days a
week and then two days a week led to
three days a week and when i got to that
point i told myself i should probably
just
get a job in restaurant and see how it
goes
he studied at the french culinary
institute and worked at new york's
gramercy tavern and dressler dress was a
wonderful restaurant one of the first to
get a michelin star in brooklyn sort of
ahead of its time if you want to say
back then it was just
us peter luger's and diner in this neck
of the woods
his wife stephanie who now helps run
meadowsweet came up with the idea of
starting their own place she pushed
really hard to go out on her own which
takes a lot of courage took a while to
persuade me to do it why did it take
some arm twisting i it's just you know
leaving your comfort zone and doing
something as risky as opening a
restaurant can take a lot
they chose to set up in williamsburg in
the exact spot where dobkin earned his
first michelin star at dressler you
could have picked any location to start
your own place yeah you chose here the
energy
both from the people who live here and
the people that decide to work here the
creative
energy is
is through the roof
at meadow suite customers get familiar
dishes with some surprises
like this burrata with figs pistachio
basil pesto and pickled kumquats and
tirine pasta with chanterelle mushrooms
and shaved summer truffle that is
fantastic
it's so creamy it's rich well this one's
all about we're going for decadence
by putting an emphasis on seasonality
meadowsuite earned a michelin star just
months after opening what did that mean
to you i was it was meant the world it
was hoping that inspectors would come
and was hoping to get a mission to start
did not expect to get it that quickly
and we've been blessed to be able to
keep it
for as long as we have his dishes with
their vibrant colors and flavors evoke
images of summer like scottish salmon on
a bed of black rice with coconut curry
oh this is different
this is not what i was expecting we make
a fresh green curry in house
and just infuse a little bit of coconut
or infuse a little coconut milk with it
and that's the foundation for the dish
like the food the indoor herb garden
might make you forget for a moment
you're in the middle of new york city it
feels like a little taste of the country
here in the city well that was
definitely part of the plan of the
design using fresh simple dishes who's
not going to love that
that's amazing to take diners on an
escape to the countryside tell me about
the customers here what do you want them
to feel when they come into meadow suite
we want them to feel comfortable
relaxed happy um and looking forward to
a wonderful meal
and they bring that same philosophy to
their drinks and so i brought you guys
one of their signature cocktails this is
called a mighty quinn now it's got gin
lemon honey and currants from the hudson
valley cheers guys what's up nice job
where is boom um very nice and i was
gonna explain why they call this a
mighty quinn but i have a feeling you're
about to find out once you take a sip oh
yeah
it's stronger than it that it looks it's
got a little power it's not as strong as
i expected
it's the currents that help balance that
out everything that i had there had this
amazing balance of
fresh flavors and this really this
tastes like summer in a glass it really
does i love that he also uses herbs from
his father's own garden it really
showcases how it's a family business in
some ways there's a whole story in every
single dish that we had there including
the drinks and his father was a big part
of his cooking journey
i love the name meadows sweetie it's
sweet sounds cool right great thank you
michael nice job thanks michael